posso entrare se io da non sei nuda però
delle mutandine potresti anche metterti
ciao zia workshop famiglia a trapuntata
h mi abbracciò degli agenti ragazzi
davvero diverso io sono fa vj poi ci si
è tornati su android che sarebbe il
videogioco per bambini posso so se lo
ricordate quello dove c'è la pupazzetto
giorno è innestata nella statua persona
pensavo fosse una persona che con
creazioni mai ma sti che appunto ci
aveva portati grazie di aver importato
da te molto sentita perché c'è una
macchina su quest'isola che non si sa da
dove secondi sia spuntata probabilmente
da dalla tangenziale e mi ha portato qui
in questo posto perché giustamente cioè
questo tizio ciao tizio si perchè perchè
cesta musica cosa è successo da quello
che ho capito dallo scorso episodio
praticamente ea cena giorno è che ci
sono sei molto bella
ricordo che stavo scherzando scheda ma
io dico ascoltami realtà sto dicendo
vattene affanculo
insomma barcaccia baccalà non ha la
possibilità non mi prendere sul serio
sui ragazzi sono stava dicendo che non
ci vado più lì c'è nel senso [ __ ]
prima era un'isola abitata e poi è stata
disabilitata qualcuno si chiede perché
io non me lo chiedo c'è io non mi faccio
domande ci sono morti sto gioco che si
aprono senza che qualcuno ti stupri
chiedo è non lo so
evidentemente sì
questa sveglia è uguale a quella che
avevo io prima di andare a scuola lui ha
rotto tutti gli specchi forse perché non
voleva vedere il suo riflesso che senso
lo voleva vedere soli freni e non mi
vengono infatti non vedo un cazzo cosa
può dover ha infilato quel cazzo di
specchio di due metri
ragazzi ho trovate uno specchio vendo
specchi ragazzo credo credo di aver
capito
ciao zio a te lo dico e c'è una tizia
veramente brutta però ho scoperto
ho scoperto ho scoperto che c'è uno
specchio che posso piazzare qui perfetto
ecco quel momento si brutta è quindi hai
visto quanto sei cessa vecchia pazza
bellissimo è svenuta dalla bruttezza chi
ha inventato sto ciò che un [ __ ] geni
che è più o meno la stessa mia reazione
quando mi alzo la mattina vado in bagno
mi guardo allo specchio stessa roba e
cioè noi che cambiano però ma [ __ ]
appello lezzi che bello di incontrarne
non ha solo serio posso stare attaccato
al muro grazie perfetto l'ho trovata
ragazzi dovrei essere a posto in teoria
le sony fi torna indietro senza salta
per cortesia grazie molto gentile
prefetto celo celo celo perfetto ci
siamo all e ci siano nè di che cosa ci
fosse un pacs beh mi sembra ovvio che
dentro un baule perciò messo sei ore per
trovare un tempo ma poi insomma e dopo
infilarlo sotto la statua so cosa ho
capito una volta che mi infilo che non è
proprio una ascolta mission lo so che tu
non lo si tampax di soul ma crimi che
non fa male
come faccio a saperlo perfetto o che si
incassato e che cosa devo fare
ho capito sarà servito a qualcosa gira
lo stato oppure l'ho girata
completamente a caso acea me che ho
messo io ma ditelo si è aperto un muro
con l'asta ok ci siamo ragazzi sono
dentro giorno sono fa di genio siamo a
ibiza i ragazzi voi non lo sapete però
questo sta dei flashback si ricorda di
quando è stato ibiza ciao zia è morta
giusto è che poi tra l'altro dovrebbe
essere mia moglie e credo sono sveglio
posso prenderla manata è uno stronzo
appello sono svelano nomini se n'è
accorto pugni io ho infilato un destro
in bocca se ce la fa sono vivo sono io
posso muovermi posso muovermi non solo
vedo niente ci abbiamo provato ma niente
ormai siamo dentro chi cazzo è quello
salve sono famiglie che giorno cos'è oh
mio dio no va bene a chi ride tornato a
great non è quello riporta ricordo con
la emi trainer questo riporta come qua è
scordati io posso aiuta possa aiutarti a
sciacca
prossima volta mi faccio i cazzi miei ma
manco di striscio d'aiuto stavo
scherzando il mio dio non è che non si
può neanche sei un pezzo di mer ai
presenti pezzi di merda i cibi ciò
skrillex ho trovato un cd di screen
ascolta zio e posso mettere un po di
musica t'incazzi dammi una [ __ ] mano
sky l'ex angelo ok via via via via via
via via via veloce sul campo il bello
ragazzi che è lo fissa cioè non è non è
che prova a capire cosa succeda non lo
fissa così ma [ __ ] sembra una frittella
tra l'altro 3 grazie illuminati sia
grazie grazie vita mia grazie perfetto
anche la porta di camera mia mamma mia
disagio ma qualcuno lo [ __ ]
[ __ ] amico via posso passare senza
che mi stupri la nonna grazieee bella
nella mia insegnante di italiano era più
aggressiva
invece no guarda non voglio entrarci
nella tana zio ebbero devo passare di
qua prefetto nel meraviglioso
io mi ha migliorato la giornata c'è un
distributore di bibite su un'isola
deserta chi cazzo raccoglie le monetine
mi scusi c'era la coca cola lei grazie
molto cendon cioe gli spiccioli bero
d'arresto e salve che cazzo è sta roba è
da lì che arriva al kebab lo avete
scoperto oggi il 20 frate altro morto a
ciò è ovvio c'è ovviamente sono porto
ragazzi non so come ma sono certo che ha
l'ascensore perfetto quindi l'ascensore
adesso funziona grazie mille servono
suona non s'è mosso che bello come
quello in filosofia più o meno ciao a
casa dopo la visita è amico mio non
sosta per caso arrivando il tizio di più
veloci veloci veloci grazie non si sa
mai tra arrivi al tizio vero quindi fai
velo perfetto
credo che sia morto perché escluso tutto
non so cose a caso ma ce l'ho fatta
perfetto siamo arrivati dove vado costa
minchia di ascensore c'era un tizio
scalzo seduto dove vado cioè sono fuori
mamma guarda che non sono stato io giuro
merda
salve via via via via via deviazione
sulla barca sulla barca tuffati tuo per
buttati in fi tipo la sirenetta non c'è
una barca perché meno male cosa fa no no
no non chiusa la cosa lanci ma come
sforno allegato certi che stop c'è un
tasso di proprio che voglio incazzarmi
tranquillo ho fatto esplodere un isola e
il tizio mi ha lanciato un barile e sono
morto da te un oscar a questo gioco non
ho veramente capito ma un cazzo ma zero
non è vero sergej bi'lin coop di
bilancio cioè solo il cervello ha fatto
lo dire ciao ragazzi quest'anno al
finale di lamber island è stato io non
lo so c'è perché è stato troppo strano
c'era non ho capito da un certo punto in
poi non ho capito un pene però la mia
mano che vi sia piaciuto anche se è
stato un po così finale ma il gioco è
stato abbastanza figo e un senso del suo
documento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook e con il video data notizia
prima di concludere ragazzi volevo
soltanto ricordarvi che sta per finire
con testi carrefour quello che ostra
detto ridetto e ridetto e potete
parteciparvi facendo la spesa in tutti i
supermercati ipermercati carrefour anche
quelli più piccoli sotto casa sotto casa
ma la descrizione ricordatevi che nel
caso la vita vi faccia qualche torto
lanciate dei barili
perché servono da ragazzi